as tensions continue to mount between
moscow and kiev western leaders have
imposed harsher economic sanctions on
russia but will they make a difference
[Music]
now the uk and our allies will begin
begin to impose the sanctions on russia
that we have already prepared boris
johnson has announced that the uk will
impose sanctions on five russian banks
russia is bank general bank from the
azbank and the black sea bank sanctions
are also being imposed on three very
high net worth individuals in the uk
freezing their uk assets and banning
them from traveling here
the u.s and europe have been talking
toughest when it comes to sanctions on
russia at this point in time and without
the certification nordstrom 2 cannot
operate
in europe olaf schultz the german
chancellor has announced that germany is
pulling the plug on the nordstrom 2
pipeline that's the undersea pipeline
meant to ferry natural gas from russia
to germany
losing it will hurt germany and other
european countries who rely heavily on
russia for their energy supply but it
shows they're serious
joe biden has set the stage for strong
sanctions calling the russian moves an
invasion
so i i'm going to begin to impose
sanctions in response
far beyond the steps we and our allies
and partners implemented in 2014. he's
already announced sanctions that ban new
investment trade and financing by u.s
persons to from or in the regions of
donetsk and luhansk here's why
vladimir putin has said that he
recognizes those two breakaway regions
of eastern ukraine as independent states
i consider it necessary to take a long
overdue decision
to immediately recognize the
independence and sovereignty of donetsk
people's republic and the hans people's
republic
and he's ready russian forces to enter
the donyatsk and luhansk regions
many see this as violating international
law and ukraine sovereignty
western nations have a range of options
in which to inflict more financial pain
on russia the most severe of these
options would be to disconnect the
russian banking system from swift the
international banking messaging system
used by more than 11 000 institutions in
200 countries worldwide
russia has taken steps during the last
decade to diversify its assets away from
the us dollar and into other assets such
as gold and the euro that makes it less
dependent on the greenback and less
vulnerable to potential u.s sanctions
russia's u.s dollar reserves have more
than halved over the last five years
so the chances are that the sanctions
unveiled will have little impact on
russian individuals close to mr putin or
the companies that they control
still less will be the impact on the
russian economy or mr putin's war
machine
it looks as though the heavy lifting on
this front will have to be done not by
the uk or the eu but by the united
states
you